you know the right wing is really hard
on the Frankfurt School you know on the
Frankfurt School were these kind of
neo-marxist guys who combine Marxism
with Freudianism in the 1940s and and
they were avowed neo-marxists know so
it's not like I'm making an accusation
and they were kind of anti system type
people and and all of that but I think
to lay what's happening at the
universities and in brought in the
broader culture itself at the feet of
the Frankfurt School is insufficient I
really think that it's primarily a
consequence of the French intellectuals
who and this is obviously an
oversimplification who emerged out of
Marxism in the early 1970s and produced
post-modernism now the thing about the
the post modernist types is they're
nested inside Marxism they they say that
straight-out I'm not inventing this you
read Derrida who's like the the joker at
the at the head of the post modernist
movement and I mean Joker because he
sees he's an intellectual clown and that
doesn't mean he's stupid because he is
not stupid
not at all these people are not stupid
they know exactly what they're doing
they know precisely what they're doing
they're a hell of a lot more educated
about what they're doing than you are
unless you happen to be one of them and
they mean exactly what they say just
like people always do when they tell you
what they're going to do or they write
it down and they say straight out on
their websites say that women studies
websites we think the patriarchy is an
oppressive structure that should be
broken down to its core and they mean
core conceptions it's not just social
its linguistic philosophical and
attitudinal it should be broken down
what wiped out and restructured from the
bottom up and they mean that so when
it's not accidental any of this and I
know it sounds like a bloody paranoid
conspiracy theory but you know I've I've
always been of the idea especially for
reading young that ideas people don't
have ideas ideas have people and these
are powerful ideas there's a good book
called explaining post-modernism that I
might recommend by a guy named
named Steven RC Hicks and his first
chapter which is very long as a good
introduction to political correctness
but so well so why do I think this is
about about that
well her here's my reasons I mean it
doesn't seem to be about me I think all
I did actually was actually I made the
general specific K which is kind of what
you have to do if you really want to
make a point a point right that's one
place if you want to make a point and my
point was I'm not saying made-up words
generated by postmodern neo-marxists
because I despise everything they stand
for and so I'm not using those damn
words and that's that
[Applause]